are you doing Bert I'm doing good
congratulations on the Big Ten
Tournament championship oh thank you
Albert I appreciate that I thought you
were gonna say that
on my 40-yard dash time now you kind of
threw me for a loop there but uh but
yeah I'm happy for you it was a great
run by John Beilein it's unbelievable it
does it every year it seems right now
it's all good
what's going on with levy on bail Albert
well there's gonna be an almost
impossible con term deal to do because
you know you you look at the number and
it's 14.5 4 million dollars so what the
Steelers have to convince him to walk
away from now is one year at that number
and then free agency next year and we've
seen in the past when there have been
outsized numbers on the franchise tag
when that it becomes almost it kind of
becomes very very difficult for teams to
do deals and so the Steelers get between
a rock and a hard place and this one
their navigate really really creative to
get him to consider anything obviously
he's shooting for the moon on this one
and and he should because your shelf
life at that position is limited and so
you know I think we're right back to
where we were a year ago for there's
gonna be lots of pumping and pumping on
both sides and we'll probably have to
check back you know where this one is on
July 1st so now that that figure is at
large because it's his second
consecutive franchise tag remember ok
because you know a lot of those numbers
are based on you know guys who are out
of the league now like Adrian Peterson
is one you know we're but the running
back number grew in the past and the
actual salaries the position scale back
that's what makes it so much different
than other ones so you look at the top
running backs in the league and they're
making nine million eighty half million
eight million dollars a year and you
know whether on bail I rightfully so
should think more than any of them you
know but based on the number of that
franchise tag what he'll be asking for
is just something that would completely
blow the market up and that's what makes
the idea of doing a long term deal off
of that tag number so difficult so and
Steelers have no desire to be a
trendsetter in that regard right that's
not the deal they put wish that the only
took fun of him last year would of I
really taken a running back market to
another level you know I think now what
he looks at is well how much is a
Antonio Brown making how much is Julio
Jones making and by the way this is
something that sort of can affect like a
Rob Gronkowski to where guys are at
different skill positions whether your
tight end or your running back become
prisoners of their positions and they
say to themselves well I mean as much to
my offenses Julio means to the Atlanta
offense or Antonio Brown means to the
Pittsburgh offense so why am I not being
rewarded that way a lot of times those
are the things that these players can
look at and the reality of the situation
is different positions are just rewarded
at different levels and the franchise
tags really do do the job of locking in
values of those certain positions which
is one of the reasons why we're here
where we are with Bobby on bail right
back after being in the same spot a year
ago and levian saw his teammate carted
off perhaps never to return to a
football field so you know he self
football mortality in person and and
interestingly enough Jarvis Landry
mentioned Ryan shazier about not wanting
to sign the franchise tag and yet where
do things stand with him and the
Dolphins right now I know the Dolphins
are gonna be aggressive in trying to in
trying to move up and whether or not get
that done we'll see my understanding is
at this point he actually accepted the
franchise tag he's yet to actually sign
the document yet but he's accepted the
franchise tag was a bit a smart move
here because that number that 16 million
dollar number is really separate guys
like Julio Jones Antonio Brown and you
know it's it's not set for slot
receivers and Jarvis Landry is
absolutely one of the best slot
receivers in football on both productive
guys in his position in all the sport
but it's always been challenging for
teams who do deals with slot receivers
we saw Victor Cruz a number of years ago
because you know that the franchise tag
number
seppius on outside receivers not on slot
receivers and I know the Dolphins aren't
willing to go anywhere close to fifteen
or sixteen million dollars a year
problem is they tagged him at that
number and so does it make sense for him
to do anything less you know I think you
would probably say what makes sense for
him to do if he's locked in at that
number and the Dolphins can't trade them
is to just play the year out at 16
million dollars and then hit free agency
next year albert pre here in the Rich
Eisen show we hit free agency a week
from tomorrow where do you think the
Kirk Cousins of it all lies right now I
think a lot of its gonna come down to
his priorities you know and I think I
mean and this is based on talking to the
people over the course of the last
couple of years here I think a big part
of this is going to come down to a team
making the commitment to make Kirk their
franchise quarterback he had a front row
seat to what that looks like with Robert
Griffin his first three years in the NFL
and I know he never quite felt that way
in Washington he never felt like like
I'm their guy and they're gonna build
around me now I think that really
affected him and I think going through
the year two years the last couple years
affected him and so look I don't think
that you know is going to become one of
those things where he's just going to go
but they get to a team that's making me
that that's putting the biggest dollar
figures in front of them but I do think
the structure of the contract is going
to matter so whether it's the Jets or
the Vikings of the fonkoze think we're
the guaranteed money is gonna is going
to matter and are you guaranteeing the
money into the third gear are you really
committing to me
committing to make me your franchise
quarterback to the next three years
that's the sort of thing I think I'll
matter either Jets are fully in on doing
that and they've got an important weapon
and Jeremy Bates we know what Sean
McVeigh and Kyle Shanahan met Kirk
Cousins and Jeremy Bates is from that
coaching tree so I know the Jets are
there the Vikings and Broncos have you
know we can win now as a weapon in this
thing I think whether or not those teams
are willing to go to the point where
they can say you're still going to be
our starting quarterback in 2020 and
this contract here says that it's going
to be sort of one of the deciding
factors and in how this whole thing
plays out next week Albert it's crazy to
me
we have reached the part of the NFL
world where the highest paid quarterback
in the league is we're talking right now
as seven career starts good god the guy
who is about to break the bank and free
agency is looking knowing he's gonna
break the bank is looking for a
long-term commitment because people are
going to break the bank on him because
they know he can put up numbers they
have no idea what he can do in January
because he's never won a playoff game
this is so bass awkward it's it's insane
you know what you want you know ice
unique though rich try to think of a
quarterback okay these conditions a guy
who's a young enough to be the answer
for a team that might be going to a
rebuild like the Jets B is experienced
and accomplished enough to be the right
kind of quarterback for a win now team
like the Vikings and Broncos and C is
healthy like I honestly I go back to 25
years of free agency and a player like
that ever hit the market before I mean I
don't think so you can throw breezes
name out there he was hurt Peyton
Manning was hurt just it just doesn't
ever happen you know and so if you're
the Vikings and you're sitting there you
get the twenty ninth pick in the draft
and you've got a roster loaded with win
now players like Anthony bar and
Harrison Smith and Danelle hunter and
Stefon Diggs and Adam Thielen and Kyle
Rudolph and Dalvin cook like you look at
that roster and you've got the 29th pick
in the draft and hey you know this is
the guy who could put us over the top
it's just rare that that sort of answer
is out there for teams and Kirk Cousins
is and that's why it's smart for Matt
Ryan and Ben Roethlisberger and Aaron
Rodgers to just sit back and wait right
now
drew Brees will probably get signed over
the next week we're going to see where
Kirk Cousins is gonna go and those
numbers are going to go north towards 30
million dollars a year and that Ryan and
Rogers and Roethlisberger can sit back
wait those guys signed then they can say
their team's hey look I'm a better
player than that guy and they'll be able
to push the market even further No
last one for you Albert based on what we
saw at the combine and say kwan showing
up
Josh Allen thrown 170 yards in the air
Baker Mayfield having definitely a
better arm and a lot of people who
hadn't seen him play displayed that
Lamar Jackson out there as well working
out a quarterback what is going on in
the Cleveland front offices right now
with the Kirk Cousins sweepstakes about
a week away less than that with the
tampering window if you will and then
what do you think's going on right now
and the Cleveland Foreign Office's walk
me through that yeah my belief is that
Cleveland will either take a quarterback
first overall or trade the pic to a team
that will and I've heard a lot of people
argue that maybe they take state quantum
Berkeley for our overall and then turn
around and draft whoever's left in
fourth here's the point I would make to
you on that if you are comfortable
enough to take a quarterback would be
fourth overall pick which means you are
necessarily tying your job security to
the guy it makes no sense not to take
him first overall the position is too
important if you get it right the guy
gives you stability for 10 to 15 years
if you feel comfortable enough to tie
your livelihood to a guy with the fourth
overall pick then you don't mess around
you don't get cute you just tape the guy
first overall now if they don't think
any of these guys are that guy then you
don't tape a guy first or fourth and I
know they're still going through the
process I talk to Dorsey about that he's
what could these quarterbacks going back
to before he had the job so you know
he's got an idea on each of them and
where is that unusual but if they
believe one of these guys is the guy to
build around for the next 10 or 15 years
on that's around I don't care how good
they go on Berkeley or Quinton Nelson or
Bradley Chubb are you just take the guy
for the first overall Albert great chat
we'll chat down the line no question
about it as news pops all right all
right you got to take care of other than
that albert bre on twitter so Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience